first it's my brain dump
we're now just a week away from the
queen's platinum jubilee a full day
celebration of britain's greatest ever
monarch and her 70 glorious years on the
throne i'm genuinely excited about this
i mean all the hideously depressing news
at the moment war school shootings
economic crisis this is a chance for my
country to put a smile on the world's
face by doing what we do best pomp
pageantry and one hell of a party it's
also time to pay tribute to a remarkable
96 year old woman who's always
represented the very best of british
values dignity humility hard work
stoicism selfless duty and the stiff
upper lip
unfortunately jetting in next week are a
royal couple who represent the complete
opposite the duke and duchess of sussex
the southern england county that i come
from incidentally where they spent
precisely three hours are a pair of
undignified whining hypocritical virtue
signaling selfish waste rules the
privacy demanding poverty preaching
carbon conscious couple will fly 5 000
miles spewing 1.5 metric tons of co2
emissions from their 11 million mansion
in california accompanied of course by
the netflix documentary camera crew
currently recording their every move for
a kardashian style reality show
the emissions of most concern to me
however are the noxious toxic fumes they
will inevitably emit from the moment
they land here and try to make the
jubilee all about themselves
banished from the buckingham palace
balcony for the trooping of the color
opening celebrations next thursday it's
not being reported they will
nevertheless be at uh with the queen at
a thanksgiving service in saint paul's
cathedral on friday build is the biggest
royal gathering since their wedding and
i'm already shuddering at the thought of
how this fame hungry duo will hijack the
headlines from the woman who should be
getting them purely to cement their
rival royal brand and satisfy of course
their netflix pain masters any place i
want to see them beside the queen in
public is that madame tussauds
frankly i'm also bemused they're flying
here at all given that megan's father
thomas lies seriously ill in hospital
after suffering a stroke megan and harry
love to preach about compassion
uh yet they showed none of it to their
own families if they had an ounce of
real compassion they'd cancel their trip
to the jubilee and visit thomas markle
in hospital that would be the first time
incredibly that harry would have ever
met his father-in-law but that would
also mean missing the chance to further
exploit their royal status for big bucks
and that ain't gonna happen
in a blazing protest against canceled
culture best-selling author and feminist
firebrand margaret atwood has created a
one-of-a-kind burn proof copy of her
book the handmaid's tale which is
auctioning to promote free expression
[Music]
besides being a very clever publicity
stunt she makes a very good point it's a
scary moment in our cultural evolution
with people lining up to cancel books
they consider problematic
where have we seen this before
oh yes nazi germany this is what happens
when societies go fascist schools in the
us have de-shelled books like of mice
and men and the adventures of
huckleberry finn over apparent racism
concerns in the uk universities of act
shakespeare and attempts to decolonize
creative writing we've even seen
classics like to kill a mockingbird
sidelined
from for promoting a white savior
narrative
but it was published in 1937.
of course it's dated these are not
manuals now we ought to think now
they're works of literature that reflect
the times in which they're written it's
teachers jobs to provide context to
inspire debate not indoctrinate our kids
by only teaching today's wonky woke
values because guess what as ricky
gervais always tries to tell them those
values today will soon be outdated too
well catherine berbelsing who's a
prominent head teacher at a school in
london has spoken out to say she's
worried that some classics will
disappear altogether eventually she says
we will do away with cultural icons like
shakespeare i do think that dead white
men are really important
now she's not against adding more black
female authors to the curriculum she
points out she is a black woman but she
thinks there's still a lot to learn from
dead white men and she's right who
wouldn't want our children to bask in
the beautiful words of these literary
giants
if music be the food of love play on
shakespeare of course it was the best of
times it was the worst of times a great
charles dickens
and the world's gone nuts
i think you all agree a classic it's
just i'm not actually dead yet
she was a face of us daytime television
for almost 20 years and also the
self-appointed face of the hashtag be
kind movement busy work but then having
two faces has never been a problem for
ellen degeneres whose final show is in
america today here she is at her most
insufferable
thank you for being here you're here on
a special day i'll tell you that today i
don't know if you know this but it's
world kindness day
since i preach kindness every day this
is a big one for me this is like my
super bowl or or my
world series or my
i don't know any other sports that's all
well ellen's show was billed as an oasis
of calm and kindness where celebrities
were her best friends and lavish
donations transformed the lives of the
most deserving in society and even had a
logo reading be kind to each other the
only problem was that behind the scenes
she was just about the least kind person
in the history of global television
staff reportedly endured an endless
toxic bullying culture of discrimination
and sexual harassment for which she
eventually issued a groveling on-air
apology this tweet from the archives
aged about as well as an open yogurt in
the desert
i made one of my employees cry like a
baby on today's show honestly it felt
good
now she might have been joking but
that's exactly what was going on behind
the scenes so goodbye and good riddance
ellen because like so many woke
celebrities you're a complete fraud
here on censor we'd like to support the
little guy the people who slog and toil
through every hardship to keep the world
spinning and tonight i want to pay
tribute to the people who do the very
worst jobs in the world there are quite
a few candidates the cow backside
inspector for example
or boris johnson's secretary for
defending the indefensible mr chaps
it could be the cleaner of this
warehouse
but we do have a late entry and i think
a definite winner how about being the
other half to the world's worst
celebrity narcissist madonna age 63 is
reportedly auditioning for a new boy toy
after spitting from her 28 year old
backing dancer lover presumably because
he's now far too old a source close to
the cringe-making singer said the
thought of gray hair or wrinkles is a
massive turn-off what she wants is a
hard-bodied hot guy in his late twenties
right but has anyone given any thought
to what that poor guy is going to have
to deal with
[Music]
whoever that poor guy turns out to be i
wish him all the very best of luck
because he's going to need it